okay
i think
we are live
i think so i hope so
hello
can y'all hear me
for one
hi kyle
i'm mr flasco
yet wait i don't i'll call you mister
you can
sweep
well hello everybody
good morning
good afternoon good evening wherever
you're from
i'm just gonna watch the intro
oh yeah i could do this first but hello
good to see y'all
i haven't streamed in a bit like i think
a little bit over a week i haven't
streamed um
it's night for you pablo it is 10 30 in
the morning for me
so that's neat
hello
hi kim's musha gold pablo c
banana monkey
hello
10 30 a.m
okay so today
yeah this is quite the challenge
i don't
i'm sorry i'm eating some grapes
i don't know if it's possible to do this
but we're gonna try
if that sounds cool with y'all
i kind of want
if you guys want
you guys tell me what character to pick
or what class to start because it
doesn't matter
you let me know we'll make it work
up to you i'm gonna let chat choose
i hope they're not shiburi grapes cause
uh apparently those are bad
it is it's gonna be interesting demon
i'm kind of excited to try
[Music]
thank you musha
wretch really
i've never played prisoner
what's so special about prisoner
level nine
actually these stats are solid except
for faith in arcane
these are actually like good
holy [ __ ]
you can't do selfies questline because
that would ruin the philly and dung
eater
right i i think if we do them in a
particular order though
it is still possible
potentially i think i think you're right
but we'll have to wait and see
good morning fernando wretch is fun is
it when you start at level one
is it fun
[Music]
i don't know about that
dude i'll i'll just keep feeding on
these grapes bro
dung eater opie
yeah i'll kind of let chat decide like
what build we go for here i don't i
don't care
it i've heard two of you say prisoner
and two of you say wretch
[Music]
what's the best i would say samurai is
the best one right just overall
i think i want to do prisoner i've never
done prisoner
since you get more total stats well i
mean
i think it's harder to level up
initially just stopping by to say hello
hey nephew oh
it's brandon
thank you man thank you for the 10
super chat i appreciate that thank you
man
i hope you're having a great day
i really appreciate you
i'm about to give up on elder ring i
can't for the life of me be ratagon or
the elden beast
you'll get it
they're hard
that that is hard you can also leave and
get stronger and come back
you start weaker but you're stronger in
the end
yeah
i think you're right um well i mean
let's just choose something right i my
first playthrough i did vagabond and
really enjoyed it
um i'm gonna go with prisoner it seems
like most most people are saying
prisoner
let's just go with it
all right
this one
is devildog for the super chat
devildog picker
boom
thank you man
oh my controller disconnected
okay well we gotta do
we gotta do this right
i mean this is just
this is just perfect this is your second
playthrough i've actually beaten this
game around six times
[Music]
dax is great early
i think you're right
thank you venesh
i appreciate you
i don't know what currency that is
because i'm uncultured but thank you
[Music]
gigachad
all right we'll go with that let's just
get it going
what what is the best keepsake i don't
think i've ever looked at this properly
to know
i i don't think i have
i don't i honestly i don't think it
matters
like you're gonna get health
you're you're gonna get
you're gonna get seeds
but you might as well start with the
seed right
yeah
i would think most people pick seed
ever considered having chat on screen
um
i have
but i think youtube has a good enough
chat on the side to to make it not as
big of a deal
um
but yeah
i think it takes up too much room on the
screen i like i'm very minimalistic
[Music]
that's indian rupees well i appreciate
it thank you
let's just go for the seed screw it
let's go
i'm gonna i'm gonna watch all the
cutscenes and everything too
while reading chat
that that is the giga chad is very well
done
the fallen leaves
tell a story
yeah they do
i think like i i don't know about you
guys but i found an excess of keys
the great elden ring
was shattered
i will die to the grafted scion i have
never beaten that thing
across the fall unless on new game plus
i'll think about it drake's
no
queen giga chair
is nowhere to be found
and in the night of the black knights
godwin the golden
was first to perish
dude i want to know more about him so
bad he seems so interesting
we know almost nothing about him
about uh godwin
ring
all i know is he looks like a piece of
poop
the mad taint of them iceland
greetings from missouri
triggered the shattering what do you
think of the theory of america's
betrayal betrayal of who the golden
order
i think that's pretty much a given but
the all-knowing
leading to abandonment the all-knowing
by the greater will this narrator goes
hard at this bro
now
he tarnished
he dead
who yet live
the call of love
speaks to
thank you very much kristin that's
really nice of you thank you man
[Music]
chieftain of the badlands
that narrator goes hard there dude it
pumps me up every time
it's so cool
and one other
whom grace would again bless
gigachad
christian thank you again dude i
appreciate the kind words and the and
the good vibes man thank you
that helmet is so weird
to stand before
the elden ring
do you think they meant to rhyme there
because they ruin it right here and
become
the elden lord
if they left that part out and left it a
rhyme
i think i would have liked it a little
bit more but
that is the whole point to become
giga chad
i chat
the narrator all the voice acting in
this game is freaking incredible
this is not i have not looked in this
room
very much
oh
that's just the tree
yeah i don't think anything's in here
the giga chad rises
i saw someone say earlier that they cut
uh godwin content
i would imagine if they did that
it would be for uh
it would be for
dlc probably
gold mask wasn't paid enough
goldmast don't talk
okay i've never used a prisoner before
so hold on a second what do we got here
what
text
text
text that's my maiden
no i won't go back up there
well she's dead
that sucks
whoa
okay
yeah this is an island you see there's
stormville right here
you can get back here
that is possibly
magic glint blade
okay
text
text
all right time to die
might as well
owned 107 dang
that's bad boys
that's bad
nerd
up we're dead
oh man
it's so weird how you you technically
died but you can still move after
dude true jack it's actually the entire
storyline of corin
i'm so bad at pronouncing names i don't
know if you guys noticed this but i
accidentally called latiana latina
in one of my videos and i felt like an
idiot it's like goddammit i [ __ ] up
of course it was the one that got taken
down
still wonder the tarnish did outside the
lands between they left as an army to
struggle and die but that was long ago
uh are we playing as a soldier of
godfrey's army
well we're all like a mix of everything
i do think we're all once with godfrey
though yeah
fortune is on his side
we found him here after all
hi dylan
one of his kind is sure to seek
the elden ring
one of his
kind what do you mean even if it does
violate the golden order
are you playing online no
no
i'm not
i'm his long-lost grandson
honestly knowing from software we're
basically a nobody
millia miliana
for melania
it's so hard to tell like it's so hard
to pronounce names in this game properly
all the time it really is
just wanted to thank you for the let me
solo her monologue about playing elden
ring however you want made me enjoy it
more got my third strawberry yesterday
congratulations
that is awesome
i love that
good for you
i'm glad i could help with that
gigachad needs no assistance
you think i need a tutorial
damn he looks good he looks good
okay
did we try and kill
the
horse boy outside
life outside the land between the darker
ages of history
yeah
do you guys think that outside the lands
between is like all the other games
like bloodborne dark souls
we're just right in the middle
that's that is a theory i've heard of
and i don't think we can completely
discredit
giga
if you don't okay
well we have to try
it's good every time walking out there
every time
fare
long time no see man
gigachat approaches vary
of course you have
no shame in it
unfortunately for you
however
you are maidenless how does he know that
without guidance
without the strength of runes and
without an invitation
to the round table thank you for the
subs you are fated
it seems
to die in obscurity
is he just saying [ __ ]
is this guy from reddit luckily for you
however
there is one shining ray of hope i made
no plan at all
take care to listen did he kill my
maiden
with grace
the golden light
wait for real to you tarnish
you may also behold its golden rays
pointing in a particular direction at
times
that
is the guidance
of grace
a path
that a tarnished must travel
he can smell it
grace's guidance holds the answers
it will lead you tarnished to the path
you are meant to follow
even if it leads you to your grave
and yet people are confused on what to
do huh grace grace's guidance will
reveal the path forward oh selvius
killed your maiden
castle
you know what chat i killed my maiden
gigachad does not need a
maiden it was me all along i killed your
maiden too
i think that's it it's time you set off
i should think to castle stormvale on
the cliff
where grace would guide you
if you it was me
he really has to rub it in doesn't he
maidenless as you
are well i have that now for no reason
okay
do i do this is there a point to this
to this killing this guy
just because it would look cool
that is the plan i have slightly in my
head fernando yes
gigachad approaches
giga chad
smells blood
giga chat attacks
oh that stays back there huh
fire
i'm scared
oh that hit him
what the heck was that
that is interesting
i don't know about easy runes
yup
how
i'm gonna try three times
because i do think i can do it
i do
i do think it can be done
three times that's it
i think so too stephen
whoops
i should probably use this more
oh
run why does he hold it for so long
i forgot he could do that
lag
run
it holds for so long it doesn't do it
pretty sure that instas you
no
oh my
i just wanted my fp
horrible timing
horrible
one more really good attempts
yeah that shield reflects back magic
boom
not easy runes
dude where are we
uh-oh
yep never mind
you have to be so perfect it's not even
worth it
on the theory of the other regions being
from other games there's a shield called
the sunrim shield
with white towers and a sun of an old
and forgotten land
and orlando
hmm
potentially
that is a thing
okay we're gonna go get torrent
and then we and then we outtie
we're gonna go get torrent we're gonna
go talk to bach
we're gonna go talk to
i forget his name but i know where he is
i think it starts with an s
i gotta i got a starting plan here we're
good we're good we're good
oh we're gonna talk to ronnie
we're gonna talk to our boy here
kalei
use the power of friendship poggers
we can talk to hayetta yep
or irena
i think they're the same person
but i can also see we can talk to
sheldon
i will definitely need help with this
chat so any help is appreciated
i am of a nomadic people
selling wares as i travel
the land has been tainted by madness
since the shattering of the elden ring
it's only tarnished like yourself
who keep things from drying up entirely
so i'm lube
yeah we can talk to blide
i would go from kenneth
to blide to the castle of kenneth
to bloodhound with
blind i have a small plan we we got this
what kind of bill do you plan on doing
on this run whatever you guys want
i'm letting chat pretty much kind of
decide as we go along
i thought that would be fun
all right let's go get torrent
nagakiba
maybe
i think bleed is still the strongest
build in this game
right well it is ronnie but she tells
you she's rena because she doesn't want
to tell you who she is
she apologizes for lying to you
in ronnie's rise
is frost still good for real
funk
hmm
oh god are you guys gonna make a meme
build
oh god
i did a build like that too christian it
that was like my second playthrough it
was really fun
you guys are gonna make a build where i
only like use butt slam or something i
feel it in my bones
we're gonna use our butt to beat this
game
no i wasn't saying rena is ronnie ronnie
just tells you she's rena she lies to
you and then apologizes later for it
greetings
traveler
from beyond the fog is she um i think my
audio's [ __ ] up but is she whispering
for you guys she's whispering for me
what the heck
i oh there we go we're good
my bad it was it was just me
i love honda
they accords the two fingers it's my
headphones i really need to get new
headphones
and aid
to the tarnish
the let me solo her build huh
i am afraid rivers of blood
katana
pot on the head i can play the role of
maiden she's doing asmr exactly
the double identities are a big thing in
the game yes
also everyone is sketchy as hell
listen if we find some wacky stuff that
you guys want me to use
i'll use it okay
we're gonna go along normally
but i will
i will side with chat
to turn runes into
another
strength
fisty i bequeathed to you this ring
that is a build
it's a bleed build
tore in use it
to traverse great distances
it will summon a spectral steed
named torrent
did you guys watch my video from last
night on her on melania
i thought it was pretty good i was very
proud of that video
okay let's add our charge because that's
what we used off the rip bruh
uh that's fine
okay bye
yes it was good thank you
another mata
i queef
i
bequeath you this ring
um
let me grab
this really quick
i forget where the entrance is
leave me alone there it is
do a baby head only run
dude it would be so cool if we could do
some sort of plug-in to have chat
like pick stuff for me i guess we that's
what chat's for but like imagine if like
twitch chat or not twitch chat excuse me
imagine if youtube chat tries to
to beat elden ring with inputs from the
chat that'd be insane
and impossible
all right bach
where you at colleen
yeah yeah
help us out
what does that mean
for have a great day hawk
oh yes
it really would be historical
some claude turned me into a tree
you were just breaking the spell weren't
you some claude
the name's bach
i was pushed out of the cave
told not to come back
not ever
he is a spectral steed
lucky you came along that's why he glows
oh what a shame
when they threw me out of the cave
they took everything i owned
and so this is me her friend
i didn't know that thank you i hope you
can forgive me
thank you for the mushroom bock i really
appreciate it
if you can afford to wait for a while
i could sneak back into the cave and
bring back something of actual ah
interesting
so i have to gather myself
but the seamster start knocking just
thinking about that god awful cave on
the shore
okay we'll do that with him
later pretty sure that's the end of his
dialogue
we can now go
back
here
for
ronnie
that would be cool jackson
this way tarnished may i have a word
she's so
like
scary to me
i don't know why a pleasure
like she she just
like precludes confidence
crazy confidence
and upon looking into the matter
the talk is of thee
thou art possessed to the power no
to call forth the spectral steed named
torrent
i can ah
as i had hoped
i was entrusted this for thee
by torrent's former master
she'd step on my balls
there's a valve calling forth spirits
summon them with it
from ash and return to the earth
the spirits will obey thine command but
briefly
as they recall battles past
now it is dying
to do with as thou wisest
oh chad i want to i want to ask you guys
something
have you guys played dark souls 1
and you know what the bet of chaos is
it's like known as like the worst boss
fight in all of from software bosses
fernando knows
if you play dark souls 1
there's
there's a boss called the bed of chaos
and
it is it is very well known there's no
way from software doesn't know either
that it is
widely expressed as the worst boss in
all of from software games right
you could go look up so many videos on
why the bet of chaos is bad it's just
not a well-designed boss fight at all
basically everybody hates the bed of
chaos
and i did i did hear of this
um
i believe i heard this on twitter
that bed of chaos everyone hates it
and then and then you look at bach right
the uh the seamster that we just talked
to
he is
he hates the way he looks that's kind of
the entire questline he hates the way he
looks he wished that he changed um and
he feels like everybody hates him
now what is bed of chaos
boc bed of chaos
bach
i think that was on purpose
i've never heard the name bach in my
life
but you know it's elden ring so i just
thought that was interesting like a very
cool little thing there
yeah ceaseless discharge was easy though
oh wait
forgive mine intrusion tarnish i think
it's a stretch but it's possible
but all the same
learn well the lands between
how long will it be i wonder
before the tarnished tire of a basins to
the two fingers
bye ronnie
byron i love you okay sorry i didn't
mean that um
hey just asking your thoughts on why it
had to be godwin that ronnie chose i
don't know
no clue man
no clue
all right i think we need to
hmm
where where should we go let's go
let's go talk to rodrika get all these
people out of the way
when you first encounter ronnie you can
see the moon in limb grave yeah that's
why it turns tonight i think they wanted
to visually show that
lord of frenzy is the canon ending
i don't know about that
yeah i think we can make our way to the
right also like guys i i can't just go
to like every character i need to like
level up and stuff i haven't done that a
single time yet
you know like get some weapon upgrades
grab a weapon that we might want to use
something you know
or this can be a tough time
i just think it had to be a demigod
eli
and joey
why it had to be godwin i don't know
[Music]
they'll take like a chunk out of your
butt to like fix uh like if you cut your
finger
take a chunk out of your butt and sew it
to your hand did you know
if you're grafted by the spider
you become a chrysalid
it's quite a lock when you think about
it
sitting sideways
you're all on your own are you
and heading to stormville yeah skin
graft enticed by the one in the white
mask i suppose
oh you've come to be one with the spider
well that makes us two peas in a pod
but i don't have your courage
it's scary you know having your arms cut
off
she's talking like it's normal
i
this little one know
with i think it is here
jelly
deserves someone braver than myself
and
the spirits look rather fondly upon you
they really don't talk about grafting
outside of godric that is true uh that's
that's why i really don't know much
about it
okay sorry my
my headset is really
fudging up here man
there we go it was a pleasure to see you
oh
can you pass on yeah i do think she has
to be grafted she also says that they
all came here for her
which i wonder why that's the case
i'm sure they'll be joining their club
soon enough
why for her
this whole pain thing you know okay
now
i need to i need to level up guys i need
to go
to
i mean
do i just use the uchi
which is right over here
i'm gonna start with the uchi we're
gonna level it
and then if we find goofy stuff
it will be used
might be a band noble
oh wait wait wait wait
really good uh
smithing stone spots here guys
right here
three smithing stone ones
gucci with frost nice
nice
[ __ ] it dude
get some rooney boys why not
oh god
ow that hurt
why
okay right here
[Music]
sorry it's scary
i press the button there we go
sick dude
ow
there's so many things in this game that
can snipe you
yeah we're not doing that i'm sorry
that's just not a thing that we're doing
is the death bird
quite literally my least favorite fight
in this game
any death bird
terrible
horrible
i didn't talk to bernal i should have
is she's a royal of some sort yeah i
just don't know where like probably from
somewhere beyond the fog right
what oh that was weird
howdy papa
godwin could have taken the place
america and ratagat america were are not
separate so ronnie yeah i agree i think
godwin probably was one of the people
that would replace
radagon
it's not sure
howie
hi survivor
the camera exactly
i just hate
the death bird fights are just not fun
they're just not
speed run
speed run
what is this
okay
we got it boys wait
ah
game of the year no doubt you guys think
so
oh
you guys think elden ring wins the game
of the year
has anyone else never used the runes
because you want to save them for later
but never
even never because you want to save them
for later but
i always use them right away actually
that's just me though
like not right away but definitely
oh i can't even use it
shoot
man
what do i need 15 decks and what do i
have 14 i need one level
but
heyo bet
is that a level
easy peasy boy
we're zooming baby
let's go fight this dude
don't see anything else
i don't either
for me specifically this is like a
perfect game
but i know that's not the case for
everybody you know
was he limping
they all limp don't they
that sucks
[Music]
what a scaredy cat
oh
yeah he came he already had like
two-thirds of his health
i rolled but i had no stamina
that was not the time to do that
i've also never listened to the music
here it's really good
i'm back i'm sorry i love you how are
you how's today fantastic kyle how's
your day going
we're backing up all right i'm going at
it
no stagger
bro this guy is a
god he's probably still injured from the
night of black knives i just don't know
how long ago that was
you know
nope
okay hold on
see how well this works
no the pole
no
oh
pain
there we go
let's go kyle
well let's go
is the brightness too low i mean we are
in an extremely dark cave
so it's gonna be dark my man
her dungeon
gg
no level
rune level wait rune level two
well no never mind i pick prisoner
i'm just wrong ignore me
vigor
leveling bigger every time
might as well throw this on why not bruh
okay what can we do while we're out here
we can do
we can do alexander
our boy
if i don't get stuck in a tree
hello
yo
it's a
boy
i'm so happy to see you
i am alexander
also known as the iron fist and as you
can see i'm stuck here
we'll see kyle it's an attempt can you
help me out of this
probably jason yep my thanks a thousand
thanks
just give me a good speech thank you for
the subs guys i appreciate
pop clean it i'm sure
don't dally
no there's no need to fret and i'm very
welcome
give it your all i say
who is mario who's that
there we go
oh sorry
well played good son well played
oh that
mighty wallop of yours almost spelled
the end of me oh the boss on the boat
yeah yeah yeah
well
i'm out now thank you ricardo i
appreciate that
the pot literally likes
being hit yes
thank you my man pleasure is mine
i am the warrior jar known as alexander
iron fist
true true kyle
where i intend to further my education
in the ways of war
and beyond these lands lie the scarlet
rot blighted caled wilds
and upon their southern edge is red main
castle
in which a festival of combat is being
held
i'd heard whispers of such festivities
before
doesn't the notion set your breast of
flatter
first time i heard this it really did
like it it is so cool to hear about a
festival
somewhere
yep he said that okay
okay we got him now we can go down here
i think we can beat the boat chick
pretty easy actually and then we can
talk to d
nope this is a completely new game
new game plus would have made all this a
lot easier though that is true
but i thought might as well just do it
from the start
i don't want people going but you're on
new game plus that's not a realistic way
to do it all in one playthrough
you know how people are
these guys are sad
and they hurt
[Music]
rip
they never like actually attack you well
i guess they do it they're
after you attack them but they're just
trying to get their head out of that
thing
um can i afford these
one okay i'll come back
no you're
good
never apologize
for being you merchant
okay we got d
death has here its mark once again
yes yes it has yes yes
what's the theory next video theory
gonna be i don't know
ah mariner
the village here has been touched by
death
turn back while you still can
does he know that i'm giga chad
apparently not
i'm still eating grapes
i need to stop
thank you kyle i appreciate that man
it's been fun
also dealing with this uh copyright
strike from this dude from reddit has
been the most annoying thing i've ever
dealt with in my life
but uh it is what it is
yeah i have not um
i haven't looked in the record yet that
would be cool
this boss design is so cool but
obnoxiously easy
i hate when they just
run away
how's my dog she's amazing
i need you to kill your own
your own people here lady
there it is
there we go
wow
she almost always goes over here
could be wrong
i was wrong
oh there you are
ow
dang it i thought he couldn't reach
bruh
hunk
like isn't that sick
it's too bad she's just so easy
the reddit theory thing bro some people
are crazy it
it has been so interesting to deal with
i can't even i can't even explain
this person thinks he owns rights to
words posted online
a theory
it's very
very interesting
how would you like to earn the strength
of beasts
if you're inclined to haunt more of
those who live in death and weed their
death root
then i'll introduce you to garank
the beast clergyman
i have a matter of my own to attend to
and the beast himself wishes for someone
to turtle place
or say
very well
show me your map i already know where it
is it's right over
of there hidden gateway
it will lead you to garank the beast
clergyman
imagine a mariner in the pool party
um if you're interested in what we're
talking about i made i've made two
community posts on my channel you can go
check those out
i mean i'm willing to talk about it here
live as well but um
there's really not much more to say
besides those community posts
so i'll go look at that
i i just hope i hope youtube gives me
back my you my uh
my video because i love that video
i love it
i think they will i've just been told by
a bunch of other
youtubers in this like i've gotten a lot
of dms from
like
people with over 50 000 subscribers on
youtube all saying like um
that this is ridiculous you don't you
know don't apologize to this guy it's
he's clearly in the wrong
uh youtube will either give you back
your video
or
they will just not want to deal with it
and
i just won't
so
either way
it is what it is i suppose
we can see a mount glimmer from here
look at that
that's cool
thank you for the subs holy [ __ ]
who is this person who is anastasia
is that talisman in town
or where is it where is it
whoa she does a lot of damage
when i have no health
oh my god
yeah i've i've looked into the quantum
tv
thing as well it's very
it's it's very similar
i like katanas that's always my pervert
preferred build
i'm just gonna let chat decide
as we go along
okay um where is this talisman
i'm curious
oh
i see
raleigh and hearing
would make sense
you know turtles
oh oh oh
oh
hello
dogs they're dogs
dog
dog
we'll see we'll see i'm letting chat
decide it'll be fun
raises stamina recovery speed lit i love
that
thank you dogs
dog
dog all right i'll stop
all right anastasia
your time is here
could this be
a squirrel
oh
this game's so pretty
nuts
kill the dog
never
i refuse to kill a dog in this game
i refuse
i won't do it
oh i should hit this
yo what up stan
i'm gonna make you bleed
[Laughter]
oh my god
holy [ __ ]
well that was very different from
the last try
she got a winning one flying man
melano
forgive me
i've been
testing you i know determine
if the elden ring would truly have you
absolutely clapped to endure this long
and arduous path
it seems my worries were unfounded
torrent had your measure from the very
start tori knows what's up
or it's one of the boys but one other
thing i can do to offer you guidance
i can take you to the round table
do we go now
no no no no of tarnished champions
guided by grace
very well oh [ __ ] i did it
for about a moment it doesn't matter i
wasn't thinking
might as well might as well doesn't
matter
it's the glomite queen
it's the rune of death
it's the kindling
it's melanoma it's ronnie
it could be queen america it could be
queen america's mom we have no idea
we can make theories
hey ah
hello again
you haven't gone to see goran yet have
you
no
no rush
you do as you please
just as long as he doesn't starve to
death hey
true
oh i see you've just arrived
welcome to the round table hold this guy
is probably the biggest simp in all of
elden ring i teach incantation he sees a
guy drawing his finger in the sky and
idolizes him
and explore the secrets of the golden
order
so that one day i just heard that in one
of the comments of my video from last
night someone said queen america or
melna could be queen america's mom
and i'm just like well i guess we can't
completely discredit that proper form
over men
by the way
do you still see it keep the grind going
kyle the guidance of grace
no yeah i do
wonderful news
most tarnished are blind to it these
days
i think so too david we just don't know
for sure
what do you say
care to learn an incantation of the two
fingers
quite literally nothing we know for sure
may the golden order shine through your
butthole
you
you remind me of reddit oh this is a
rare occasion
i can't remember the last time a new
tarnish made their way to the round
table very well
as your senior
i bid you welcome
it is safe here
are you on summer break yet stan
allow me a word of advice
as your senior as your senior but a mere
visitor to the round table nothing more
a house guest
yet to earn their keep
remember your place
newcomer
okay
dad
oh
i forget about you so much hello
he must be new here
this guy's so emotional just call me
dialos
the honor of one's house holds little
import in these lands
the all-knowing have you met a young
woman named on your travels my
flashlight on my phone has been in my
pocket this whole time
incredible now i have 10 battery amazing
uh amazing
has anyone else ever done that other
than me
huh
sorry i'm reading comments
not a good idea
okay
who we got
that door's closed until i beat
godric i think you don't talk
you just want to kill me
i believe that's it
i think we need to go in level
aruchi
you're a new face
no matter
it's all the same
lay out your arms
he's so sad
i see you've noticed the chains
nothing's bad yeah sorry that was a
wicked burp i'm a prisoner and these are
my chains
i'm trapped by the hole
i'm dying smithing for you fools
that's all there is to it
i think he's a demigod because he was we
think he was born of god win
chester
we just don't
we just don't know
for sure
no
don't worry too much into it well no
grudge against you my being a prisoner
is no fault of yours
besides
my own mind smithing
despite my differences
oh yeah i did see that
given
time
never fails
besides it helps me forget
the sheer terror of her
scary
okay we need one more smithing stone too
but that'll that'll do us i mean we
could beat margaret with this
with this setup technically um
is that everyone i can talk to in here
i'm pretty sure it is okay okay
we can go
let's go help bach out
hey guys you should join jake's discord
yeah i mean if people want to join the
discord
it's in the description if you're
curious
let's go help out our boy bach
get the chain from patches oh we should
go to patches we'll do that after this
i could also level i just realized
um pretty sure this guy is smithing
stones up here as well i'm gonna buy
those if i can
definitely give a god it says so in the
terms of items maybe we'll get more info
dlc i think i think we will yeah we have
to wait a lot of info
we just gotta wait
what do you need which is fine
you do whatever your heart desires
is the buckler no okay
all done
are you done
okay go away
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh
i haven't heard that before
oh
what are you doing here
you must leave this place at once
they'll rush in and beat you to a pope
you'll end up just like me
okay
i don't know how well this is going to
go because this boss fight
sucks i should level
just thought of that
100
100
we got two
bigger bigger is important
in the beginning
if you hit bach one time now he will die
i do not want to kill bach
but that is cool to know
[ __ ]
oh
no i wanted to summon that guy
just because it's interesting
i don't know what i'm stuck on
okay
what
holy [ __ ]
dude
it's gonna be close
not even close
first try
that dude flew for a second
joe true kyle it really does
thank you for the subs
appreciate it
we're getting we're getting close to
thirty thousand which is kind of insane
considering last week we were at five
thousand
kind of nuts
[ __ ]
it's the rabbits
let me rest real quick buck hopefully it
doesn't go away okay good
says the same thing and give him a
sewing needle look at his face when you
give him this item
you got it back for me
my sewing needle
he freaks out
what made you go into a thing like that
because i'm nice i was a seamstress
and that sewing kit was all i had to
remember a boy
i always wanted to be just like sweet
old mum
oh then i
suppose i
i can't just curl up and die can i
i'm doing well dwarf how are you
thank you you're very kind i always
wanted to be okay i think he says the
same thing and now he has
a meaning to life chat let's go
bach doesn't want to die now
yay
sewing needle he becomes your seamstress
and alters your clothes for free
oh wait i should go over there
right
and i can always come back i don't care
[Music]
depression cured
uh we can go
now to
oh
who's your favorite boss radon 100
radon's awesome
whenever you get the video back you
should re-upload it with the title
well okay whenever i hope i get the
video back um
i think i'll make my own video on the
entire situation
because it's quite
it is quite insane
how some people think that i'm in the
wrong here
it blows my mind
absolutely blows my mind
malakath was sick yeah
i i really enjoyed radon the most i had
the biggest like moment with him
uh sorry
it is a very situation dwarf
very weird situation
that did not need to happen
and i did everything in my power to try
and uh do it
in a mature way and this guy wants
nothing to do with that so
it is what it is
he's he's very adamant about the truth
i don't know you guys can go to my
community tab
and and go see it for yourself if you
want
um he's trying to get me to say that i
lied
and
he's just he will not back off of that
he's like listen dude you copied my work
you're lying about it to everybody
that's technically all he wants is for
me to say that i lied and i copied his
work i can't say that because i didn't
i don't think he understands that
i'm not just gonna say something that he
wants me to say
that just isn't true
exactly the thing that suits him the
most
it's ridiculous
thank you sean hopefully my content's
good enough for that as well
flip it out of context exactly
well welcome to the internet right
welcome to the internet
get that get our wondrous physic
physic
i believe melania can talk to us here as
well
so we got your video taken down for
spreading his theory so
i mean you can go to the community post
but i'll talk about it here real quick
so i originally heard this theory from
someone named
um practical meet
i saw it on reddit i thought it was cool
i wrote my own script about his theory
and i [ __ ] up
and did not cite my source
and i felt bad because this person who's
copywriting me now
made a whole reddit post saying that i
plagiarized his work
and i assumed that the person who made
the reddit post
was the person who originally
came up with the theory right
so i was i was messaging him on reddit
twitter and discord telling him dude i
am so sorry i'll delete the video i'll
put it up with an apology and proper
sighting and we can go from there and he
would not
answer me in any dms the only place he
would talk to me was in a public reddit
thread where he could have all of his
other
reddit sharks come and beat the [ __ ] out
of me in the comments
he had no intention of talking to me in
dms absolutely
none which shows his intent to just
harass
and spread in for misinformation about
what's really going on
so this whole thing this whole thing
goes over i put it up two days go by and
the video gets taken down copyright
strike from this person and i'm like
what the heck and he said i plagiarized
his
his theory
what i want you guys to understand
is that he's not talking about the
theory itself
he's talking and copyright striking in
his mind
a comment to the theory
a comment that he put on the reddit
thread that i didn't even know about i
didn't even know he commented i thought
he was the guy who made the theory
so i'm thinking all this time he's
practical meet just changed his name or
something he's a totally different
person
which blew my mind
it blew my mind i'm like and he's still
to this day
i i talked to them talked to him in dms
yesterday where he is so adamant about
me saying dude just admit you
plagiarized and i in whatever right
the thing is i i didn't plagiarize i
can't just tell like say something that
isn't true like you want me to do
and he's just so adamant like you stole
my content and it's like dude
you don't own the rights to any of this
and he thinks he does
and and i will i will say
that what i wrote there
and what he wrote are very similar
and it's because it's oh sorry all these
allegations are crazy love your content
i i really appreciate that man thank you
i really really appreciate that
thank you for the the
wow i don't know what sck is but
it's around six bucks thank you very
much
um
so
he's very adamant about the truth and he
wants me to say something that just
isn't true he firmly believes i
plagiarize it
dude everyone is making theories from
the same sources as well youth if he
thinks he's the first person that came
up
with the theory that the erd tree
feeds on on uh not sacrifices
feeds on struggle
he's delusional
i've heard that from vatividia several
other youtube videos i've watched he is
not the first person that's come up with
this
so it would make complete sense
that me and him wrote something very
similar for that
80 second segment
hello
oh hi
oh calm down
but
no stop
sorry
so
sorry my dad came in
he
i forget where i was talking about
he doesn't
i'm choking
i'm good
oh my god
okay
i'm choking
anyway
oh this this guy
is just so
crazy
about about this entire thing so he is
claiming
that he owns the copyright
to what he wrote in a comment on reddit
he even sent me the copyright laws in
the united states
where he thinks that any form of you
know public documentation on a website
like that is under copyright law
in the exact same article it says that
you cannot copyright concepts or ideas
theories any of that stuff
so he's just misinformed on what
copyright is
so i counter claimed him
and now we're just waiting to see what
youtube does basically
any the only thing that he the only
reason he's still going on with this
entire thing is because he thinks that i
lied
and i didn't
i just didn't man i'm sorry that you
want me to say that and i just won't
because it's not true
his words are technically owned by
reddit and everything that we make is
technically owned by from software
he doesn't own any of it
even in the reddit
user agreement when you sign up to make
an account on reddit you are publicly
like giving all credit to everything
that anything is posted
to reddit
yes a copyright on a theory of a comment
it
it's
laughable
so
it's been very stressful
because i personally don't like it
when people don't like me
i know that's gonna happen
i don't like it when people are upset
with me i don't like it when you know
uh people think i did something wrong
when i never have any intention to do
that ever
yeah i've seen that kyle a couple people
have looked up his name and he's like
he's getting it legal advice from reddit
which is just insane
he had i think he had one guy say that
he
uh
he had one guy tell him that he's in the
right and there were several comments
that he didn't talk to about like how
it's not copyright
and that he's
it's just not true
i'm worried about that to stand because
youtube wants nothing to do with this
and i completely understand why it's a
legal thing at this point that youtube
doesn't usually want to deal with it all
and they may just be like you know what
we don't want to deal with this just
keep the video down [ __ ] it
they may do that i've been told that
from several big youtubers who have dm
me about the situation the last two days
youtube may just be like we don't we
don't want to we don't want it we're out
and that's that and that will be that
but i really hope they choose to put it
back up
gilgamesh he's mad that i didn't credit
his comment
he wasn't even the person that came up
with the theory itself
he wrote a comment on the theory that i
heard it from so he was upset and told
me he was upset that i didn't credit his
comment
a a comment that i was not even aware
existed which they're never going to
believe that because they're so far up
their ass on this situation
but
that's that's the person we're dealing
with
they they see they feel wronged and they
were jealous
that
a theory similar to his
was put up on youtube and got hundreds
of thousands of views that's exactly
what happened he got butthurt that his
reddit thread got like two up votes
and
my video got hundreds of thousands of
views that's why he's doing all of this
because he's just a butthurt [ __ ]
that's pretty much it
that's the whole thing
melano
see with me with your amazing voice
spoken echoes linger here
words of queen america
who vanished long ago
if you wish
i will share them with you
see very well
in america's own words
my lord
and thy warriors
i divest each of thee
of thy grace
with thine eyes dimmed
ye will be driven from the lands between
he will wage war in a land afar
where you will live
and die
i need to stop eating these grapes
perhaps that might serve you
in you of a maiden's guidance
thank you melano
okay
can i give you lore
yes please
is this miss wood right here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
mickey and friends
mickey and friends
i'm not eating shiburi grapes chat
that would be
gross because they're technically
eyeballs
i will make sure to throw a grape at my
monitor for hayata
when we find her
all right do we find uh our boy
we find blight
which is ah bear
oh
well we don't want to go down here yet
do we no
it's so foggy i can't see
ah oh my god
i always get lost in here
there it is i'm going the wrong way
of course
how's joy doing joy is fantastic
thank you for asking
that bear was straight up asserting
dominance
it scared me
[Music]
what is after me right now okay there we
go we need to go back here
to kalei
thank you for all the subs
and talk to him about getting the
whistle animation
emotes
well you're back
care to buy something your plans for
your channel once the elder hype dies
nope
we'll see
i suppose no it doesn't mean no deaths
we already died like
once once or twice why not meet him for
yourself
next time you hear the wolf's howl
make this signal right under the source
ah don't fret there is nothing to fear
i just have an inkling the two of you
might hit it off
i do like some dogs man
sorry my headphones are messing up again
and i'm eating carrots now
hype doesn't really die off in these
games people are always interested in
playing these games ever since they come
out
like people play these games for years
but instead are forced into this pitiful
unceasing journey
but thanks to that what if another game
comes out that i'm interested in i'll
absolutely play it though the elden ring
is shattered
i think this makes us
kindred spirits of sorts
your people the tarnished
and mine
interesting perhaps you don't need to
hear this
but
see that no harm comes to my kin
i'm i'm not sure john we're kind of just
giving it giving it a go solitude
expect no sympathy we're attempting to
do this
nothing
but
if anyone dares harm us
show them no mercy no i went from grapes
to carrots
just the way we are oh dlc is going to
be so good bro i'm so excited
goodbye thank you kalei i love you
um
did i even hit anything out here no i'm
silly stupid
it's not that far away
then we can go to uh kenneth
next
when will dlc start we don't know
usually from software takes about eight
months to a year to come out with dlc
because this game is absolutely huge
yes we can do euro
and we can do patches as well
uh after kenneth
since that's sort of on the way to um
the bloodhound
the bloodhound fight with blight
you think we're gonna be on the moon
that would be cool
uh no not yet
kyle not yet well i'm just kind of going
with the flow and and making content you
know
have you beat the game if so who is your
fav boss
i have i have beaten the game six times
yes
um
all with around 50 hours
um some or less some or more
my favorite boss fight is radon and
thank you very much for the two dollars
i appreciate that
thank you
that's very kind of you
i'm gonna get rid of this bear
bear
ah
what is happening
but thank you again kevin
very very nice of you thank you for the
help light
i appreciate that
thank you man
jesus jesus
okay so we got
switch
snap
pop
so graceful
yo
who goes there
carly sent you diddy
never the bloody busy body
hmm
maybe to him you don't seem so strange
the name's blithe
we will get dlcs and likely a sequel
absolutely he fled somewhere nearby this
game was a major success wouldn't you
guys say
this game was more successful than i
ever could have imagined it would be
darawil is nothing but a traitor pusha p
and in need of a fitting
you have 150 hours and still yet to
complete the game see a lot of people um
like my first playthrough was 58 hours
where i got credits at the end the thing
about that is i didn't look up any
guides i didn't you know i just went
with i just went with the flow
and
i found out later on
that i missed a whole bunch of content
but i wouldn't know
because i didn't i've never played the
game before you know what i'm saying
okay we need to go back up here actually
got it
[Music]
so i play the game again totally
different way 50 more hours get credits
missed a whole bunch of other content as
well that's the beauty of this game i i
think there's still
many things that i have yet to discover
in this game
and we'll keep finding new stuff out for
years to come
and it's gonna be awesome
bats
i hate bats
kenneth
yeah you guys weren't even gonna play it
if i didn't hype it up in the discord
stand
you guys were like what's elden read
and i was like trust me dawg
you about to find out
am i stupid
where's kenneth
he's more this way right
i think a dlc or two is definitely
possible but a sequel with the endings
of this game would be unimaginably
difficult to figure out
i mean they did it with dark souls twice
so i think they can definitely do it
it'll take years we won't see that for
five six years
so
yeah yeah
yeah there's some hidden door that takes
like
20 hours of perfectly perfectly
orchestrated
sequences to to open a door okay there
he is
something like that
where is raya why did selvis die exactly
that's why i love it
now
hi alan how are you
is anybody there
someone who might be interested in
rescuing the great kenneth height
servant to the true order and celebrated
repudiator of the false
can you not see me dude
[Music]
grant me what does he mean by sucker
like like we're gonna fall for it
um also
how many how many of you guys have
played other dark souls games i know i
asked this earlier but
yes or no is elden ring your first from
software games
it's very kind but um
no would be uh the question i guess the
help is very much appreciated
even from a tarnished
despite appearances nobility is no
prerequisite to serving the true order
you might have heard of me
kenny's height
a lot of yeses that's great
that's awesome
i would have a boon of you
i want you to take back my fort
it lies to the south beyond the mist
wood
a knight commander from stormville took
it secures a from software game
counts
what kenneth what are you waiting for
a kiss goodbye
i've never played demon souls that's the
only one i haven't played
take it back for me
oh i see
you wish to know the reward
fret knott
the great kenneth height is known for
his considerable largesse
the celebrations will be lavish indeed
upon the dawn of my forced retrieval
jake bragg do you think you'll go do you
think you'll go back and play them now
that you've played elden ring
like all to all the people who
if eldon ring is your first from
software game do you feel more
interested in going back and playing the
other games as well
because i will tell you they're all
really good
bloodborne is incredible dark souls 3
was my first from software game back in
2016.
that will always hold a very special
place in my heart dark souls 3 was is
incredible
i'm not a fan of dark souls 2
but i know a lot of people are
and it is great
dark souls 1 is amazing
but i think is starting to show its age
but is still a really fun experience
shaqiro is incredible to this day it's
only like three years old sakiro is
awesome just a completely different
combat experience to this game so
be weary of that
if if the first game you played is eldon
ring go play dark souls 3
absolutely this this game is very
similar to dark souls 3.
yeah the swamp is annoying stan but
that's like you're probably 20 through
the
i game agree jack care to avoid godric's
tarnished hunts where i in your shoes
there is a charm to dark souls 2 there
there is i mean i beat it i just didn't
enjoy it
as much as the others
which is hard to do
lord
don't make me laugh
first he hid himself amongst the women
folk to flee the capital then hid from
radon in that castle that is also true
spades
rather than die like a man
has he no shame the big girl's blouse
and to think he's the blood of godfrey
last of the golden lineage
you almost wouldn't know it to look at
him
so he is the lineage of godfrey that's
confirmed right there
he just said that godric is the linea
lineage of godfrey
so it is
well technically that no no that still
doesn't confirm that because
godwin is the lineage
of godfrey as well
so technically you could say
that godwin like being the son of godwin
is also the lineage of god free
that okay so that's interesting
very very
interesting bloodborne is very cool i i
bloodborne is
freaking incredible
okay so we talked to kenneth um
we need to go
do patches right
or we should
yes
i almost hit i almost just swung my
sword at kenneth
that would have been bad okay
god freud
yeah it could be a great grandson like
yeah
do you guys feel like we know anything
100 in this game because i don't
i feel like nothing is truly a hundred
percent
hey bloodborne on twitch was a vibe
until twitch ruined it by
existing
what dark souls do you think is the best
in my opinion dark souls 3.
but that will definitely change
based on the person
here we go
thank you alan
who's your favorite lore character or
story oh god i'm dead
i was reading chat
dang it
oh god where am i okay
oh we damn well know that melania is the
blade of nicola
we damn well know that oh yeah
she told us a few times
no it's my fault it's not chad's fault
see i don't think fast traveling would
work
in dark souls one the whole point of the
game
is that the uh
the level design is interconnected
together
very intricately
like
if you look into it it's kind of crazy
how
how it is
how do i get down here
from from this direction
i need to go down there
oh i got it
let's just not die this time
i'm sorry i'm annoyed with myself
man you can really get stuck right here
holy sh
holy shish dude
okay there's no way we make that jump
it's just not happening
[Music]
i don't want to die again
i don't want to die
[Music]
am i going to get copyrighted for that
because i sang a song
i'm sorry i'm all my butt hurt
you know what
um
i'm stupid and we need to go over here
first
so i did all of that for nothing
because we need to talk to our boy
and probably beat up a dragon
i commented on that song once
you're stealing from me
wow
hi cole
how are you sir
this isn't the first open word from soft
uh
it it is the first open world yes most
of the from software games are very
linear
here we go
you're never late pascal ask all you're
never late can't be
must be the new tarnished yo you do want
to steer clear of a deal like fledgling
dragon
rooster
and it's as fearsome
as it is majestic
so
unless you're mad
or wish to be burned alive
stay clear of the lake
don't be a fool
turn back
before it's too late
oh that's a good look at his face right
there
first time i've seen his face
look at that
[Music]
confirmed
he is our dad
all right chad let's go to the lake even
though he told us not to
just kidding i'm gonna go over here
first
grab this boy right here
i have a theory that the greater will is
inspired by beyond good and evil the
book oh the greater will will be
being a life force that seeks power
power and order
it could be
very well could be
naga kiba
very adamant about the naga keeper
oh
what's this
oh unsheath cool
you guys know that there's a dude up
here that turns into a bear and gives
you a larval tear
let's do that real quick
what's going on right now in general i
am attempting to do every quest line in
the game in one one new playthrough
all right check this out i don't want to
do that yet
he went down and killed people
uh
there you go
bruh what are you doing
there you go
gigabear
give me my larval tear yay
why does he turn into a bear i don't
know
he does
won't killing a rune bear make blight
hostile
no
i don't know why i would either
i'm gonna level up sorry
i don't wanna wait
do i have more of these
i do
i'm the best
around i didn't level up because i'm
stupid
i use a controller
all right what are we putting it into
15 15 of this is not bad
i wouldn't mind being near six hundo
though
let's do two of those
one of those
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's a sweden
imagine being dead
i mean technically right now you can't
die in elden ring you always come back
to life
because the rune of death has been taken
away
when the shattering of the eldering
occurred
i shouldn't talk like that i may i make
videos like that like am i making fun of
myself
i love this hitting things as i ride by
i don't know why i enjoyed that so much
it froze
no
wow that was long okay here we go
oh yeah
yura are you gonna come help bro
that's not good
the end is
you're dead
nice
we should do a reduvia play through that
would be kind of sick
what do i need 13 arcane
little dagger playthrough
um
level 22 with that thing
yo heck yeah
all right we're going to patches
thank you for all the soaps i appreciate
it
thank you thank you thank you
do it you won't all right bet it
bet
i like how you enter a boss room for
this interaction it's kind of weird
i'll let uh chat decide billions
i'm dead
and
did i just parry his kick
oh adult dating
hold on
do not touch that account
i surrender
finally come round have
[Music]
hold on
wait a minute
wait a minute
i might fold
i'm gonna fold
oh i should make people moderators huh
kyle you want to be a moderator
cole
hi user on this channel
are they gone
the users messages will be hidden
are bots a big thing on youtube i'm
pretty new to youtube not gonna lie
especially youtube streaming is that a
thing
like that i'll do it all right but um
add moderator
all right where's cole
let me go back and find cole
sorry chat
we gotta do it
oh we got stan making him a moderator
we got coal
moderator boom
all right we got three
they're infested in youtube
interesting
well that wasn't too big of a deal we
took care of it pretty quick
well what do you know
you're tarnished like me
now how did i get that wrong
i took you for a demi-human or something
an innocent mistake i assure you
well water under the bridge
now we're squared up how about we play
nice from now on
okay a true man of reason
just what i like about you
i'm patches
patches
short range has been annoying yeah with
the redubia you have that ash of war
though
[Music]
have a great rest of your day patricia i
appreciate you hanging out
we'll see you again soon
showing them the ropes
but honestly
this looting bracket is bloody
terrifying
frankly
i'm ready to wash my hands clean maybe
set up a legitimate shop
we're definitely getting the shackle yep
i'll be ready to wheel and deal come
next time
[Laughter]
i'll come back
i think i've seen them in other chats
before
it's it's usually when i post a new
video that i just see
uh like bots like that post weird [ __ ]
in the comments and i always just report
them for spam
very interesting indeed
i like the sound
for some reason these guys remind me of
dark souls 2.
maybe i shouldn't have done this
that load up
what is that
who's swinging like this
there we go
oh you become a mod and then leave i'm
just kidding
i'm probably uh not going to be
streaming for much longer
i kind of want to spend the week uh
streaming for two to three hours a day
actually
see how that goes well nice of you to
drop in finally it's all a bit ad hoc
have a good day work kyle sure you'll
find something hi claudia welcome to
patch's emporium
where you won't need a refund because
everything's top-notch
where everything is top notch
five thousand
jesus patches
my man
i didn't buy anything
cheers for not buying anything mate
oh my god
[Music]
sorry
all right we don't have enough
we'll have to come back
also that takes you to miss wood
don't touch it
yeah
i don't think it's valuable either i
don't find margaret to be that hard
anymore
but
it's so cool to have
but i don't think it's worth 5k
it's kind of nuts dude okay
so now we can go and help blight
if you want the cheese
you must please
i don't know
forgot what i was going to say
volcano manor he doesn't say cheers for
that what a nerd
all right we got blight
jesus he's tall
kane of godric and i have never known
ambition
justice
no
this is where it ends for you
whoops
get him blight
oh
oh
okay
finish it where'd he go
what
what are you doing
there it is
let blight do it
giga chad
and the furry guts duo
way better than god's skin right
everything's better than godskin duo
he well you have to talk to him
beforehand if you want help in this
fight
that's why you didn't see him
right there you are
not to work for it but it's done
don't say i'm not a man of my word and
you get a somber 2 out of it
huge value
oh yes
i should say if you venture north to
rayo lucaria and come across a venerable
blacksmith who's a little on the large
side
eg he sent you
and he'll be sure to treat you right i
owe you one hurricane
that's enough chit chat for now this
time we parked in waves
yeah you get a somber two for that bye
blight
i love you okay um god i don't think
there's
we're gonna save caleb for later um
i think we're gonna end the day
on beating
margaret
what's the beef uh you don't like that
guy
he does not like that guy
that's all i know though
yeah he called him a furry
now that i i i've always i always like
this fight i know a lot of people hate
the market fight
i love this fight it's really it's
really fun once you learn the the
moveset it's great
we got one level
nope not worth
i want to do arcane for the reduvia
eventually right
oh um i wonder if i can level my weapon
actually
let's go back round table
one question weeping yes i think we'll
save that for tomorrow i'm really gonna
try and stream every day
uh for i would say the next week just
for like two to three hours
i'm gonna take a little bit of a break
from uh from lore stuff
but i'm still working on them
no matter if they have your arms yeah we
already heard all that
i
can't
okay well we go back
ye
oh we gotta use roger
roger
roger's one of the boys
yeah stop by if you want to boys
thanks for all the subs
come on raju okay
this right here and people say that the
graphics in this game are bad
there are people who say that and it
kind of blows my mind
imagine having that opinion
couldn't be me
tarnished
emboldened by the flame of ambition
hmm
someone must extinguish
absolutely awesome
i'm dead
roger
mods
destroy
mods destroy
fall off
first try let's go
my mods are slacking
i don't know just like click their name
that's what i did
here i'll do it
hide user in chat
you don't type anything you just click
their name kyle i did it for you
yay
bot spot spots
no stress
they're just weird
oh i did i banned him um well that was
easy they're er than i thought it would
be
i think that's fine okay
boys
and girls
wait i want to look at this first
yeah this game's ugly by the way
bad graphics right
bad graphics
thank you mohammed okay
ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls
i'm gonna call it for today
we are going to explore stormville
castle
and uh morn castle tomorrow
and then we'll probably move on to like
caleb and and uh
ray lucario and stuff like that so
i'm getting off for the day
i really hope you guys have a great rest
of your day thank you for all the
support lately uh with this whole
reddit
fiasco thing that's going on i
appreciate it thank you for all the
support on just the channel in general
this channel's been popping off the last
like week week and a half so
i really appreciate it i really really
do you have no idea um thank you for all
the support all the subs all the you
know all the super chats and stuff today
was really really fun
so i'll be back tomorrow around 10 a.m
cst like i did today stream for two
three hours and then
you know we'll just try and carefully
work our way through the game and
hopefully can try and get every quest
line in the game in one playthrough and
i think that's it was fun i like doing
it today so thank you all very much and
i will see you
manana
ban those bots
all right have a great rest of your day
guys peace peace and love
here let me ban them real quick hey kyle
did it perfect
thank you kyle all right i'm out of here
guys bye bye bye bye bye thank you so
much